more now on this morning's breaking news
that the high court has ruled that
shamima begum
should be allowed to return to the uk to
challenge the decision
to revoke her british citizenship the 20
year old was 15 when she left the uk in
2015 with two school
friends to join the so-called islamic
state
in syria well let's get more from our
defense and security correspondent
aleister bunkel who's following the case
from west london
alastair yeah adam so um
shamima begum last year when she was
found
in uh a camp being uh held by syrian
defense forces was stripped of her
citizenship
uh by the then home secretary sajid
javid
partly on the basis of national security
and because of the justification that
she also
had at the time bangladeshi
citizenship so the british government by
removing british citizenship wasn't
leaving her
entirely stateless she disagreed
and she tried to appeal that through her
lawyers
at siak which is the special immigration
appeals commission but she was
unsuccessful
now her lawyers have now successfully
argued
that because she has not been allowed to
return to the uk
to appeal this decision in person
that she hasn't been given a fair
due part of the process and she should
be allowed to come here
in person to appeal the decision and to
put forward her case
the court of appeal in london today um
has decided and three judges came to
this decision
that and i'll read the exact words ms
bagan should be allowed to come to the
united kingdom
to pursue her appeal albeit subject to
such controls
as the secretary of state deems
appropriate now that's the home
secretary
now of course pretty patel not sajid
javid
this as i understand it will go back to
sayak the special immigration appeals
commission
for more consideration because they have
expertise in this
but what it does in a nutshell from
shamika babum's point of view in her
lawyer's point of view
is it really bolsters her case that she
should be allowed back in this country
albeit
inevitably under very strict controls in
order to try and appeal the decision
in person to have her british
citizenship
reinstated